Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman Show.
I am Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire, sitting in
for David today as he enjoys a nice little break
from all of the insanity happening in the world
of politics. So let's jump right in to all of
that insanity. Late last week, a judge, Judge
Arthur anger on the one overseeing Donald Trump's
upcoming trial for the $250 million lawsuit filed
against him and his kids by New York Attorney
General Letitia James. Anger on ruled last week
that Donald Trump's new accounting firm cannot
continue to shield his financial records,
and they must turn them over to Letitia James.
Now, you may be thinking to yourself, but,
Erin, the judge had already ruled that Donald
Trump's accounting firm had to give all of this
information to Letitia James, right? MAZARS
Donald Trump's accounting firm was ordered to
turn all of the financial documents over. They're
vital to the case. That is true. So Donald Trump
did what most major corporations did, and he
employed a tactic known as the Texas Two-Step.
Typically, we see it in corporations facing
billions of dollars in lawsuits. What they do
is they create a new subsidiary, spin off all of
the liability, but none of the money into that
subsidiary then filed for bankruptcy, saying,
Hey, you can't sue us because we got no money.
Now, Trump's little scheme here, his version of
the Texas Two-Step, was slightly different. What
he did was as soon as the judge said, Hey, Mazars,
you got to turn over this financial information,
Trump said, Okay, Mazars, I'm taking it away
from you and I'm putting it down in Texas,
where they have very strict privacy
laws with a firm called Whitley Penn.
And so for the last few months, Whitley Penn,
who now holds Donald Trump's financial records,
has been telling Letitia James that, hey, sorry,
under Texas law, right, this guy is our client.
You know, we love him dearly. We've known
him for days. We can't give you his documents
because Texas law prohibits that. So Inger on,
of course, was forced to step in and say no.
No, you can't do that. I had already ordered all
of these documents, regardless of who held them
to turn them over. And that was when the documents
were in fact, by the way, in my jurisdiction here
in New York. They were moved after the ruling.
You have no claim to continue to hide them.
So Donald Trump's financial documents should.
Should is the key word be handed over to Letitia
James so that she can continue on with her $250
million lawsuit against Trump and his kids.
Now, this is probably going to be appealed.
That's what Trump does. He he does the delay
tactic. He tries to exhaust all of his appeals
so that he can make sure he's fought as hard as
he can to hide these documents. But again, when
you look at the facts of the situation, while the
documents were in custody in New York, they were
ordered to be delivered. They were moved after
that order came down. WHITLEY Penn should have
no legal claim to continue to keep them hidden
because the order came while the documents were in
the jurisdiction of the judge. Like, it's pretty
black and white. It's pretty simple. I don't
think this will or could be overturned on appeal,
but we've seen some wacky things
come out of the court systems,
not necessarily with regard to Donald Trump. He
tends to lose a lot throughout most of his life.
So I have every every faith that this ruling is
going to stand. But it is quite telling, isn't it?
Trump was ordered to turn over these
documents rather than turn them over. He
decided to hide them. Now, I'm not on the
jury. I haven't seen the documents. All I
can do is speculate at this point. But if I'm
looking at this case as a prospective juror,
because they will know that the documents
were moved. All right, this public knowledge,
I'm going to be asking myself why, after he was
ordered to turn them over, did he go and hide them
in Texas? That that doesn't sound like something
that somebody who is totally innocent would do.
Does it? Again, I'm not on the jury. I'm not in
New York, so I won't be on the jury. But those are
questions that the prosecution may ask during the
trial. And those are questions that Donald Trump's
rag tag team of second rate attorneys are going
to have to have some pretty dang good answers
for. Otherwise, it's only going to make Donald
Trump look guilty as hell in front of that jury.